So because I was looking for a team and
not someone for a specific task,
I didn't do any programming
skills tests or
any other things like that that you
can really quantify the result.
I gave a few companies
the same exact project
that I had ability to evaluate myself.
It was a reporting project.
I wanted them to connect all kinds
of data sources to one dashboard,
and I told them that's what I need.
That's the brief, go out and execute it.
You have 100 hours to do it.
Do whatever you need because one of
the things that was important to me is
to have also product abilities.
Not just following orders,
it's also to envision what you want,
what I need them to do and
execute on that,
because they didn't want to
micromanage them, I can't micromanage.
So that was a test that he
passed in flying colors.
It was way better than what I would do.
And then I know okay,
we're going to work together for
a long time, because this is exactly
what I would expect an employee of mine.
To do better than what I would do.
To be better at things
that I did in this.
That's why I need you.
I don't need you just to follow orders.
I need you to think.
I need you to innovate.
And that was the test.